frecuentemente en el contexto de
tarjetas de crédito y demás instrumentos
crediticios uno se encuentra con las
siglas de iu
m anual
y qué significan pues quizás ya lo sepan
o quizás se lo imaginan significa taza
de interés e interés
nominal
anual
y esto es el concepto que quiero
explorar en este vídeo así que bien
navegando por internet me topé con que
de tarjetas de crédito que se ofertan
con una tasa de interés nominal anual de
el 22.9 por ciento esta es la tasa anual
pero justo al lado de esta cifra
escriben 0.0 62 74% diario
y esto es lo que a mí me hace pensar un
poco diario porque esto significa que el
interés se está componiendo de manera
diaria tu deuda se está recalculando
cada día y bueno cómo se relacionan
estos números pues si toman el interés
diario si toman el 0.0 62 cuenta 74% y
lo multiplican por los 365 días que hay
en el año deberían obtener la tasa de
interés nominal anual y vamos a checar
que eso es el caso
veamos tengo cero punto cero 62 74 por
365 y bueno estos son porcentajes en
formalmente debería haber agregado un
par de ceros un cero por aquí para
obtener el número real pero no importa
22.900 1 así que justo es esta tasa de
interés es mala así que esto sí nos da
el latin la tasa de interés nominal
anual 22.9 por ciento pero cuál es el
problema usted dicen bueno no hay ningún
problema esto es esperable no pero la
respuesta a eso es que están compilando
el interés cada día la deuda se
recalcula continuamente entonces vamos a
ver qué es lo que está pasando en verdad
cada día nos están cobrando una tasa de
interés del 0.0 62 74% si lo escribo
como un decimal esto se convierte en
0.00 agregó dos ceros después del punto
decimal y luego
62 74 si 1% es simplemente 0.01 entonces
0.0 62 74 30.000 62 74
ahora
qué sucede pues esto es el interés que
me cobran cada día así que si quiero
calcular el interés a lo largo de todo
el año lo que tengo que hacer es
componer esto 365 veces si vieron
cualquiera de los vídeos de interés
compuesto saben que lo que tenemos que
hacer es tomar este número y sumarle 1
es decir escribir 1 punto y luego toda
esta cosa de cam 000 6 274 y ahora
elevar este número a la potencia 365
porque lo voy a componer 365 veces
lo que está pasando es lo siguiente en
el primer día veamos
ya uno digamos que tengo un peso que le
debo al banco un peso en el día 2
le debo este peso pero le tengo que
sumar el interés así que ahora le debo
un peso que es mi capital inicial mi
principal inicial por 1.000 62 74
en el día 3
en el día 3 le debo la cantidad que le
debían el día 2 1 por 1.000 6 7 4 x de
nuevo el interés
1.000 62 74 así que esto es por tres
días y continúa este juego hasta que lo
hago por 365 veces y cuánto será eso
cuánto nos dará este número
pues nos da 1.000 62 74 elevado a la
potencia 365
nos da 1.25 725 voy a redondear a 1.25 7
1.25 7 si le quito uno a este número lo
que voy a obtener es la tasa de interés
real es decir 0.25 7 o lo que es lo
mismo 25.7 por ciento y esto es el
verdadero interés que tendrías que pagar
lo podemos llamar el la tasa tasa de
interés
efectiva
anual
este es el verdadero monto de intereses
que tendrías que pagar con un crédito de
una tasa de interés nominal del 22.9 por
ciento anual y quizás estén diciendo
bueno no es tanta la diferencia pero es
importante recordar que cada punto
porcentual que tienes de deuda realmente
te pesa más si vas a permanecer con esa
deuda durante los periodos prolongados
de tiempo así que lo mejor es
simplemente tratar de evitar las deudas
a toda costa porque estas tasas de
interés son realmente altas y se puede
empezar mucho a la larga pero bueno en
todo caso lo que es muy importante tener
en cuenta es que muchas veces el interés
anunciado es simplemente nominal y no se
corresponde con el matemáticamente
correcto que sería la tasa de interés
efectiva anual